so
all right people who are joining this
live stream we are talking about
the fundamental treatment of arrays
in our language
and
i guess that the
to me one of the most obvious targets
well let's take a look at the the main
issues here one of the most obvious
targets is repeated association keys
um which is the row oriented versus
column oriented question for things like
data data set
right
i mean and i think we've discussed
before
the cons
the
concept of having
a what are we calling it association
list is that correct
what have we called it
hello what have we called it
uh i've never heard of this so i also
gonna say okay so
i think christopher has certainly heard
of it so maybe he can say something
about it
might be data framework the concept
what's that it might be data frame
no
no that's not correct we we've had a
specific discussion about this i mean
basically the idea is the following
that
you know just like it's row oriented
versus column oriented and all it's
saying is
instead of you know right now we have a
list of associations with identical
heads with identical key structures
right
and so the only point here
is to have something
where
storage wise it just looks like
presumably a bunch of you know
key arrow lists
but the true structure
is the transpose of that
am i making sense
i think you have it inverted like you
want to store it as a sock as key goes
to list but it needs to like when you
call select on it no no i know i know i
know that's exactly what i mean it needs
to walk and talk like a list of
associations but it needs to be stored
as an association of lists
right yeah
yeah
the
so i mean i think this is the thing
that in concept i believe to be not
controversial
how it should be implemented i'm not
sure but but do people agree about this
i mean for example dataset
should routinely use things like this
is it a separate head you know a
separate full form and head or what is
it
well let's think about that i mean maybe
what it is is something which says
um
maybe it's something like this
association list of this
and that
is for purposes of list operations
that becomes by the way does anybody
know where i'm storing this
i i actually i'm not sure
because we had had a bunch of other
discussions about arrays
so where are those do you know
uh no
okay well there's an array operations
array processing here we go under
functional programming okay
okay so by the way i mean for this array
list or whatever it's called thing would
it would it be restricted to being one
level deep or could it work for deeper
deeper i would hope it could work for
deeper structures i mean i would hope
what it is is a wrapper that says
you know conceptually it's like sparse
array and by the way like a bunch of
these other array types go ahead but
isn't this just a data frame i mean it
what you're saying is that the key is
basically the the head for that column
yeah yeah yeah exactly i mean what yes
but
if it's deeper if it's deeper then i'm
not sure
no of course then it generalizes that
but this is super important because you
want to think of these keys as variables
and things you know like that's that's
um what what explain that concept
okay so in r and other you know r and
python this focus is on sort of data
manipulation do you think of these
variables the keys you think of them as
variables and you kind of start using
them in various ways
and that's why they're called data
frames
i know i know i know
and
and so the type is coherent in that list
often you know for efficient storage but
of course it doesn't have you know it
could be more flexible storage but
for compiler stuff if the type is
coherent in that column
it still generalizes matrix because the
type can be different per column you can
have dates in one column and
bits in another and
sure
well fine whatever i mean okay so
i mean i don't particularly like the
name data frame i think by the time
we've got data set data structure
whatever i think um uh
you know i'm not i'm not keen on that
name
the point is that there is a there's
actually a number of these structures
that
you know work like association list but
have different
ways
but i mean conceptually
what this is like is like sparse array
that is sparse array keeps its data and
by the way this is not unreal you know
it should interoperate with sparse array
it keeps its data in the way that it
keeps its data but as far as the outside
world is concerned it is a dense list
am i making sense so i mean here for
example if you did a select on this
to extract
a single record so to speak
that select should
kind of invisibly
go ahead and get the association with a
bunch of keys
if you understand what i'm saying right
i mean so in other words this thing so
so let's take a select here okay on an
association list
what does select okay what does select
do on a sparse array
do you sound like a question
but can somebody just you might just
densify it i'm not sure well let's find
out let's say i don't think it works on
sparse array right the select only takes
one right so select doesn't have a
level spec
right well i understand that i'm saying
here if i say hash greater than zero
here
and i do that
uh what did i do here what did i do
wrong oops i'm sorry i
did that in the wrong place
um
okay and that's not a sparse array
right so identified it
right but so in this case here
we would almost certainly want
this
to return an association list
well it depends on what your well i
guess yes select yeah you would you
would but something like map it's more
complicated because with map maybe
you're just adding 12 to one of the
fields in which case it should return an
association list or maybe you're turning
each of the constituent associations
into you know a string
and then
that's not an association list anymore
by the way
sandra is commenting on our livestream
please not more data type heads
says i like the picture approach where
you basically never see it
and that is indeed something we should
talk about
whether there is a subterranean approach
to the whole thing
am i making sense uh yeah but i disagree
i mean i think that the the whole
factory business is is like it's really
hard
okay you're wrong you're simply wrong
packed arrays are one of the better you
know the fact that the implementation is
not as perfect as it could be it's just
from a user point of view you're just
wrong
i'm just saying this well it depends on
on on what the user wants to do
for 99.
even steven
stephen if the user wants to write
efficient code it is so yeah okay
let me finish my sentence stephen it is
so easy to accidentally unpack without
i'm well
i'm well aware that's our that's our
mistake but for 99.5 percent of our
users what we have is really a good
solution
and doing something where we expose it
is stupid and i'm not even going to
discuss it
but steven if this is going to be
something that is ultra front-end for
like out-of-core data if your data set
is one terabyte and unpacking means
bringing it all into memory obviously
obviously hollow carlo you just got to
be a little bit use judgment okay use
judgment it's not you know something
where you absolutely say oh my gosh we
can't do this because you might unpack a
one terabyte array of course you can
kill the idea by saying if we were
stupid it would break
right but the whole point is not to do
that like for example what we're doing
right now with dataset where it's you
know do you want to store this in the
notebook or not
there's you know it requires some
thought to see how to get those things
to work but clearly
you know and it requires some way of
having some i don't know something like
recursion limit but it isn't that
that we we have a thing right now for
the maximum
size of of forget what the variable is
called but but
that just defines the maximum size that
it will automatically store locally
right what is that called somebody knows
it i probably knows
do you know what i'm talking about
i'm sorry i missed something where what
stores
determines how big the the maximum size
before it'll ask you to store it in the
notebook so you're talking about
yes dollar inline notebook storage limit
probably but that's that's the type of
thing what really what's it called or is
it dollar notebook uh maybe it's dollar
notebook and line storage unit limit
okay
so
i mean honestly it seems like i mean
it does seem like if you had some giant
out of core thing that's kind of a
different use case from if you're you
know don't have a one terabyte out of
core thing i mean maybe
it could also be something where it does
secretly work like with a packed array
or something like that but there could
also be a top level explicit kind of
lower level way of using it where it
will never
you know densify if you know what i mean
to use the sparse array analogy
right
well anyway this is this is the same
issue exists for sparse arrays by the
way i mean which is you know you've got
some 10 billion by 10 billion sparse
array that's not actually very big but
you know if you're not careful it might
densify but i don't know i'm not sure
how big it is that's the impact sparse
arrays it's very much you could have a
massive sparse array
no but christopher is saying that
there's two things there's the theory
there's the carlo theory of it might
blow up the world
and there's the reality of does it
actually bite anybody
just like the famous x equals x plus one
could blow up the world and cause
nothing to work but turns out it isn't
an important thing
so right i mean to be fair i mean the
the operations that people are running
on sparse arrays are much more i mean
there's a much smaller set of operations
for sparse arrays and there are for some
more general data structure like this
which is why it might be worth it might
be worth having some again explicit
representation no i agree i think we do
have a limit for sparse arrays but it's
not documented and the default is to set
it to infinity
i see
okay
okay listen what that tells you is it's
like a lot of these design things
in principle it could blow you up
and there are some things where in
practice it blows you up
but that's not one of them apparently
otherwise we would have you know like
recursion limit or something like this
we would have you know set a finite
value for that but look if we were to do
packed arrays all over again
with current
design thinking
we probably would have had a way
to have an advisory wrapper and we
probably should think about this now an
advisory rapper
that says i really want to make sure
this is always packed
do you see what i'm saying
right and basically it behaves exactly
the same except if it were ever to be
unpacked it will complain it will
complain yeah well there's a message you
can turn on
i know tom but that's not the that's not
the point the point is what christopher
said isn't it no it isn't no it's not
about messages right it's about you see
the code
and you know with our modern design
ideas what we would have done is to have
something where there's a thing called
pact array and perhaps in the early
implementation of it it wouldn't be
subterranean
right in the early implementation it
would be visible but then as it gets
supported more more fully
it eventually can disappear and can
become automatically done
but if you have a list which has an
explicit packed array wrapper
then it is kind of giving notice to
functions that this thing should stay
packed
does that make sense i mean does that
mean
they're staying packed at the cost of
not working so
that's correct that's correct
that's correct tom that's correct that's
what it means to have that there right
it's it's
you know so so my point is
what we probably have done today
is something where we say this is a
packed array and it's got to stay packed
and that deals with it
hang on can i ask do you try and insert
a string into it
it will fail it will just say error
message failed
error message and you get back dollar
failed no you don't get back dollar
failed you get back probably the
unevaluated thing i'm not sure
right but but that deals with the
objection which again wasn't a very you
know of itai and so on oh my gosh it
unpacks and you didn't know it
right so in other words if you say i
really really want this code to be
efficient and i really want it to stay
packed well then put a packed wrapper
around it and if the the um
you know and if it if it turns out
that it unpacks it bounces off and says
i'm not going to do this because it
would cause me to unpack
and i'm not supposed to do that
i mean it seems like the fundamental
issue is just that you know there are
sort of pro users who want to be able to
control for example when their arrays
are packed or not
but then if if you sort of relegate
packed rays to being something where it
can only be done explicitly it'll never
happen automatically exactly and there's
a vast sea of you know amateur users who
will just never take advantage of it
right exactly and it's the same thing so
to me the best of both worlds is you can
put the explicit wrapper
or
you can just
uh you know or you can have it happen
automatically and i think that will be
the best situation
with association list and related
constructs
now i i'm not sure
that when it's a true out-of-core
operation it might be a different story
i'm not sure about that
i mean in the case of something like
video
we are
making it appear you don't really know
that it's out of core do
you
am i making something
no visual cues that says this is out of
course
right now although video is always out
of core right
not necessarily is it wasn't there an
animation image isn't that in the
notebook that one is in notebook video
is always out of core audio has in
coronado core versions and there is a
visual cue that says which one is which
well okay so so that means that if i
send somebody a notebook with a video it
will break
yes
now i mean we should be dealing with
that somehow
how should we deal with that
i mean at the very least
we probably should have the same
indication for video because for example
if you were sending somebody a video
somebody a notebook and it contains a
video
then you know one thing you could do
is at least put
that video in a cloud object that the
person can access
otherwise you're just handing them a
dead creature
that's a little dangerous though because
the reason why the video isn't stored in
the notebook most of the time is because
it's huge right well it could be huge
and so putting in a cloud object maybe
is
you know similarly troubled well yeah
but i mean the question is what actually
happens i mean we haven't really had
this issue yet because
well i don't know people are not yet
routinely sending notebooks that have
videos in them
but
you know what do we think is going to
happen there
i think that it's going to drive us to
actually solve it and i think that there
are two solutions one is
an expanded notebook format that's more
like an archive
that has assets that you can bundle in
and the other one is that you
move them
to like say our cloud
and re-link so you have to re-um
yeah you have to relink it basically to
those
i agree
i think those are both reasonable
solutions the cloud one being the more
immediate one to be able to implement
i agree
but i mean okay so that that's and that
should be the pattern also when we deal
with large out of core data sets exactly
so so this is just we already did it for
audio i thought it would be a big
problem i you know we went down these
are the two solutions that we want but
it was just not enough
incentive
or eagerness to solve it
so video
yeah this this this um large data
relocation well because we actually
because we have this audio is also big
audio i know but we can have a bigger
serious option to save in the notebook
this is not really practical
obviously obviously
but that's a different use case than
this
you frequently record like your whole
damn meeting right yes i i i know roger
i know okay but there's a different use
case that is still interesting of the
kind of you know research on sounds
where it's a five second lump of sound
absolutely sure
okay so
okay so let's come back here to
what we're basically talking about i
mean what we i think
go ahead
yeah there's one thing i wanted to add
which is other than the whole packing
thing there is a should be i mean if
we're going rappers there should be
another rapper which is called sessions
basically so you
if you're doing if you're using normal
heads or doing i don't know join and
intersection and whatnot and the data is
sitting somewhere far
you might want to have a way to say okay
group these things and do them all
together before you bring me back the
result
wait wait wait wait wait what you're
saying there
is actually do operations out of core is
that correct
no like well it's a different thing i
mean so that's what for example your
database framework does that right
you're doing actual operations you're
doing database selects and things on the
out of core database
before it comes back in right
yeah sure but what i'm saying is that if
if
databases were to be
one of the out-of-core back-ends for
association list
then you wouldn't want to eagerly
perform each
say select or
or join or intersection what not wait
for the result to come back and didn't
do the other especially since maybe the
intermediate results are too big to be
brought up i know but but what you're
saying is which we know is of interest
right
is
okay
you've got a data
some kind of lump of data it's huge
it's stored in some out of core way it's
a file on some file system somewhere
right you
have
some thing
which is not
where you know it's like a snake eating
something
it doesn't
maybe i don't really know the physiology
of snakes well enough but but my
impression is there's a lump that goes
down the snake it doesn't all that
that's a bad analogy never mind but you
you get what i'm saying that it it's
kind of going and um
uh
uh
it is never
okay in the basic operation of our
system
the concept is
you gulp the whole lump of data
into memory and then you do operations
on it what this is about and we've
started to have a number of out of core
kinds of operations is something where
it is
it is
[Music]
you know you say you sort of want to
build up you sort of want to you know
perform operations in a lazy way
yeah
right and then when you actually run it
you run it by basically calling normal
or something like that and then that
will actually
perform the operations all at once but
then you presumably you've set up the
operations that what you're actually
going to get back is small
well that's what we've done with
databases right the out of out of core
databases
what we've done is a bunch of noun
nounified names i mean let's remind
ourselves how that works
um
the uh
you know
what what we did there
and i'm not completely certain it's the
best pattern but um um
uh
you you want to look for the nc club
right but so what we're doing here
i mean that's not the right guy there
there there there it is okay so what
this is is things like
um what we have is this kind of
nounified thing sorted entity class
okay which means i want this sorted but
i'm not actually going to do the sort
right now i am merely defining that this
is talking about the sorted entity class
and then the thing that actually
uh you know when you call entity list or
entity value or something like that
that's when the actual operation gets
done
right by the way it's just a design
question i mean is there a particular
reason why these have their own heads
and you don't just call sort
yes
okay no no i'll tell you why and i'm not
sure it's the correct thing
right the reason is sort just does what
it does
right and and the the what we would have
to have here is an environment
where that code wasn't evaluated
because as soon as you actually have
sought there well i mean so so the
alternative would be
that sort of
you'd have some sort of i don't know i
mean
i imagine you could do a similar thing
with sort though couldn't you where you
have some sort of you know database
object you call sort on it and it
returns some you know processed database
object which no it's that sort has been
called on it and then you can you know
build this up and then you can
eventually normal for something except
that's the core of the notebook that we
sent out like there is a number like
call it association list or data frame
there's a number of operations that go
from association list to another
association short select and whatnot
they're basically there's this basic
algebra things you can do the statement
is making a different point the point
he's making is this design
where we
build this up implicitly
may not be the right design the
alternative design which we didn't
consider adequately for a number of
reasons which i don't think were very
good reasons
the
you know is
to have
some kind of database object thing
and to basically say
special case for sort
it doesn't do what you normally what
sort normally does on a single element
which apparently is just to return that
element surprises me a little bit but
anyway
the instead
it does some operation and so so then
you know exception for select for
example if it is applied to a database
object it doesn't do the generic thing
that select does it have to be a
database object why can't we have
something that works like that and is
just an association list i mean the
operations that you can do on something
like that are the same because i i i no
no no no no no i'm making a different
point but the whole point here
is that you are not getting back the you
know the reason we have sorted entity
class is because we don't want sort to
apply itself to some symbolic
representation of a database and just
make a big mess
instead we want something that
represents
the operation of doing sorting but we
only want to actualize that operation at
the end
yeah but
i have to say that i i've been solving
all these problems with streaming and
basically the last 10 or 15 minutes of
discussion
uh all these ideas have been already
incorporated into that so
i could uh that's good to be exposed to
people so because i've been solving all
these problems already okay but let's
let's just enumerate what we're talking
about just to be clear the alternative
design here
would have been would still be to have
some kind of database object or database
query result object
that is
um
so
okay so let's just go back through this
for a second okay so approach you know
basically this is approaches
to
lazy slash out of core operations
okay so one approach is
you know an explicit head
that
um
has
random stuff
represent you know inside it okay what
do i mean by that i mean that
and maybe there's an example of this
with video i i suspect video is an
example of this in other words video
well you guys tell me if i do an
operation like i binarize a video or
something
what what's happening is
what okay what could be happening i
don't know whether whether video
operations are always
eager or whether they can be lazy can
they be lazy
currently they're all eager but we have
discussed video filter graph ideas so
that we can store a series of operations
in a video object actually i i'll give
you a case where it's not not where it's
lazy which is a trimmed video a a um
uh what do you call it you know
something where you've time selected the
video you're not doing that explicitly
are you
that one is not in yet but we have
discussed it as a time selection option
we do have a track selection option
where that's lazy well fine all right so
track selection is then an example of
what i'm talking about here so what that
means is
um
uh
you know what that means is that
this the thing you see is a video
and
there are aspects of it that if you were
to try and get its bits out
there would be some operation which has
been held up that has to be done before
you do that
okay so that's that's one example
explicit has has random stuff inside it
where
where
where kind of where what's inside
is modified
but but whether yeah i mean this is your
filter graph kind of is modified by the
by the eager operations applied to it
does this does everybody understand what
i'm what i mean by this
maybe there's a better way to say it
people understand what i mean here so i
mean this is like saying
sort
of i don't know
go ahead i mean it's as if i mean you
wouldn't want you probably wouldn't want
to implement it like this you would it's
as if sort just returned unevaluated and
you could call all these functions
they're all unevaluated but then when
you call normal or take or i don't know
some special function like that it'll
actually run them all at once no no no
because that that's what that's the
entity approach that you are building up
something symbolic that's nested heads
here the idea is that you know that's
not right carlo that's not right the
whole point is here here
i think our own goals i think that's
that's the same thing i mean i think
these are kind of the same it's just a
matter of whether you're actually
building it up as unevaluated heads yeah
or whatever exactly you are so this is a
separate choice something slightly
different okay an explicit head that has
random stuff inside where all you see is
the head
okay yeah sure yeah so you don't build
it up unevaluated it goes inside it's
different right okay so then the second
case says
the different distinct case
is why does this have to be database
specific
it's nothing to do with databases i'm
just using that as an example
no what i'm saying why do we need
different heads for different backhands
this is this is i know i know i know i
know i know the point is that we're
talking about why is it you know
filtered entity class instead of select
right right you build up a symbolic
structure
of unevaluated operations
but but but again i mean i the only
potential issue or one of the potential
issues with unevaluated operations is
that having select sit unevaluated might
be a bit weird
but we can't do that we can't do that
unless we have i mean so there are two
approaches to that number one would be
some kind of weird inactivated select
okay which i don't like very much an
active select
a blah i don't like that
and the alternative would be
the selected entity class thing where
it's a different
where it's a oh what is it called anyway
well and then the third alternative
which i think
it's filtered actually
well or or it's just that you have that
it just modified you know it just goes
inside of the entity class at the head
of the thing that's returned to still
say entity class but that has some
arguments in it that's this case here
well we'll know because that has had
filtered entity class i'm just saying i
mean this is something where it does no
no no this first case here this first
case look the they're two cases okay yes
either yes either
you know to to be clear either we say
sort of database object and blah blah
well the alternative to that
is to say
sorted
entity class
of
an entity
that you know of something which is an
entity class or whatever it is which
stays the same where you don't mess with
that entity class thing
where that's immutable so to speak and
it's the rapper outside
that i wouldn't shouldn't say immutable
that that's that's unchanged and it's
the wrapper outside that stores the
operations
you see what i'm saying
sure
so i think these are two cases and
honestly i'm not sure we picked the
right one for this
but now now let's look at in the next
case which is
that um
you know the next case is invisible
uh invisible laziness which we don't
have yet
to my knowledge
which is invisible you mean like like
yeah okay so you mean like you you run
the operation on and it secretly doesn't
actually run it but if you for example
displayed it if you printed it to your
notebook then it would actually run it
right right right only only only visible
on serialization or something
only visible on sort of human
interaction or serialization
well stream does have all the all of
that okay i want to hear we let's hear
about streaming lynette
do you want to show something or do you
want oh well i wasn't actually prepared
to demo this today uh i can probably
just
today i could just mention a few ideas
behind which
on which it is based
okay uh really uh so uh basically there
is a single uh structure called lazy
list which is exactly this invisible
structure whenever you apply some
operation to it
it stores inside the information that
this operation has to be applied
and it also has a notion of chunking
built in so it automatically kind of
distributes that operation to
which operations have to be applied to
individual chunks
then whenever you apply next operations
whenever you chain them
it basically translates that into
chaining operations on individual chunks
and it does this in such a way that you
can still be efficient because chunks
are large enough that you can use
vectorized approach on individual chunks
and then you kind of factorize the whole
problem into a problem of operating
chunks and the problem of what happens
inside each chunk
let me see if i can summarize a couple
of things there okay so one point is
it is in principle the case even with
this kind of approach the symbolic
structure of unevaluated operations that
you could have a a program
transformation step in which you notice
that if you say sorted entity class of
sorted entity class it's like you don't
need both of those you can optimize one
of them away
right
there's a set of transformations and for
your purposes
to maintain
you know chunk integrity that is there
are things which are local operations
within chunks they're things which have
to go between chunks
and presumably you have to know oh this
is a sequence of operations that are all
local to chunks we can put them all
together versus another thing where we
have to do global synchronization before
we can proceed
yes uh in fact it's uh even much simpler
than that because what i've been doing
was basically that
you
mostly
either you are able to translate for
certain operations the operation
or on overall structure to operations
and chunks and then each chunk
accumulates its own individual queue of
operations that have to be applied or if
it's non-local like for instance for
sorting
then you have to basically invent an
algorithm that would still utilize
vectorization on chunking but it will
still be chunked in nature but it can't
be fully lazy that's the problem like
with sorting for instance it's actually
hard to invent a fully lazy sorting
algorithm
sure
yeah
let's just summarize for a second
because i mean this is very related to
parallel distributed computation type
questions right and there are things
where i mean in our modern view which
i'm sorry to impose on people about
reference frames and you know this
relates to the whole multi-computation
initiative which
some of you have heard a bunch about
about thinking about
kind of the this
this question of when do you have to
it all relates to what counts as as now
across this large data structure
because you can have basically
simultaneity surfaces across this data
structure which might for example what
you're saying is if the thing is purely
local you can pick any simultaneity
surface it's okay and so long as
eventually the things get done it's
going to work but if you have something
where you have to currently synchronize
you need you know a different
simultaneity surface and you know i go
ahead yeah yeah it's certainly related
but i think the situation that i was
considering was much simpler because
most operations were sort of referential
transparent so you know if uh you could
you could instead you didn't even have
to think that much about synchronization
but obviously what you're saying is
correct as soon as we start to
parallelize things right so
in fact i was actually designing
streaming to be kind of an easy way to
parallelize eventually because indeed uh
well obviously if you start considering
mutable operations that will become
really hard but for operations that we
were considering for streaming which
were mostly you know immutable
operations such as map or fold or split
or transpose or things like that yeah
right so for those it it became possible
to actually factorize all of them into
what you do with chunks versus what you
do with individual chunk
and apparently they were kind of
immutable in the sense that you could
process chunks in in principle in any
order you want multiple questions here
okay
so first point is from the user's point
of view
is there a thing that they see called
lazy list
well
i think it should be although in the
past we were thinking that this will be
a strictly uh supporting structure for
dataset but that turned out not to be a
good idea because okay but but we have
the exact same issues about pactorate
versus other things you know should one
see the fact that it's a lazy list i
mean i would like to point out that for
example graph
is an example where i have no idea what
its internal data structure is and i
believe that it switches around that
data structure depending on what's
happening is that a true statement
roger or other people yeah
yes
okay so that's a big success because i
don't you know i use graphs a ton and i
haven't exactly underlined geometry uses
even more data structures it's even more
data structure rich
although some of those are visible at
the top level but but maybe not all of
them yeah but some that you think are
visible actually have a big iceberg
underneath them that you didn't know
about
right well so
well i mean
my opinion based on the experience with
streaming is that
in this particular case for the chunk
list
exposing it would be correct thing to do
because it's too different from normal
list
both in terms of how it operates and in
terms of what api it supports
and our attempt to eventually support
the entire list api for lazy list was
kind of doomed from the start which is
why i think that exposing it would be a
right thing to do in this particular
case yeah but what you're arguing for
is what i was saying earlier which is
you know at the beginning you expose it
because it only supports a limited set
of operations
as you get more operations supported it
can potentially be more automated and
integrated i mean that's a possible
approach
yeah the only thing that i think
i'm not sure this is a real distinction
but i mean with something like lazy list
okay with something like packed array if
you can pack it it's always gonna be
faster right it's always gonna be faster
more memory efficient etc but with
something like lazy list
my impression is that you know there are
cases when you'll put it in a lazy list
and everything will be much slower less
memory efficient etc and so i don't know
it seems like a more dangerous thing to
do automatically or due to invisibly
yeah actually packed a race it's not
always
extracting like a row from a matrix
is faster if they're stored individually
but i want to just say that in modern
times you know graphs and geometry
are a great big success story
for
subterranean data structure
you know juggling
and we should learn from that
stephen i think one thing we could do is
like to follow a similar approach to the
compiler which is streaming with data
set sorry can i yeah hello
i mean just just let me finish it like
we could expose the data structures as
something like data structure but the
works out of core
and so if somebody wants to really
low-level stuff they can do it with that
but then there would be a number of data
structures that are exposed to that
which have a similar structure which is
like the association list one
that could all be subsumed in the same
interface a dataset like interface
normally sort and that that gobbled in
and then you could do normalization okay
look i think that the general point as i
was saying before is were we to do pact
array today we would have an explicit
wrapper that you could use
right that indicates and i don't know in
the case of geometry maybe we have a
similar situation where there are
explicit wrappers that you can use but
there is an automatic process where you
never have to know about them
right i believe that's the best of both
worlds and i believe that but that's
kind of
that's kind of how we design it i mean
we bring things to the surface when
we think that the use case is broad
enough
right it's it cannot be sort of a
graph is simpler you know it's finite
graphs if we had to deal with infinite
graphs we would have other kinds of
things but
so
it can all be represented just more or
less efficient and i think i believe
that what we're talking about in this
meeting is finite stuff it's just big
so it can all be represented just more
or less efficient
well sometimes
although there might be things that are
big to the extent they're effectively
infinite right like if you have a one
terabyte
uh out of core thing it's effectively
infinite if you actually try and and
load it all you're just as doomed as if
you tried to load an infinite thing
actually streaming does support infinite
lists uh just as well as find it so
that's what christopher is basically
saying if it's a petabyte in size it
might as well be infinite yeah so so
we're getting some we're getting states
in between but geometry have actually
uncomputable things actually
unrepresentable things
sorry that's the nature what do you feel
the the the um
a mesh region
cannot represent everything exactly
because not everything is piecewise
linear in the world
sure okay but that that so that's a
different issue but but my point
in this case we could
define as a backhand to this something
that is like a generator in the
like that thing that was in roman's book
like 25 years ago like it's a function
that is generating the things or it's an
external api maybe you know uh
one of those types of data like the
stock market so so just a second so so
let's say
you know data sources here okay so one
is
you know explicit data eg in a file
another is
a um
uh generator that's what we have for
things like video generators and so on
although i didn't i haven't liked very
much you know a
function based generator basically
i don't think that's a good example
okay but fine but you get the point here
and another is
uh external streaming data
where you know
where you don't even know where there's
no way to know what's coming
and it's you know
so
someone's mentioning that roman gave a
talk
about iterator array iterators roman
what was that about
yes i mean the iterator is a
generalization of the lazy lists where
you
the only essentially the only operation
you allow is
to produce the next element
and so they are behave just like lazy
lists but they can have more efficient
generators like compiled
think of generate all binary trees
it's non-trivial to come up with a next
binary tree algorithm but once you have
that
if you don't want to run a
select operation on binary trees you can
run
that operation on
trees that you would never fit in memory
at the same time but it's still
efficient
right
so this is the iterator
just the the kind of just give me the
next element
yes
and um
there's a lot of things that are sort of
filters on top of that like sex
how do you define a set for instance
like with a condition
and i mean it goes in into that category
of things that have their own head and
that may internally accumulate uh whole
operations like when you do a map you
you don't just do it when you call it
you you do it as you need the next
element so this is a natural
way of accumulating uh
processing in inside and you you you
don't need to know about it right but so
that's basically this example this is
you know um yes it's i mean we can call
it it's it's
it's
what are we going to say it's all in its
head not that's not quite it's not quite
the right term that's not right quite
the right characterization because it
actually isn't in the head actually it's
in the expression
by the way stephen i don't know if you
remember but a few months ago i told you
that i had a
you know an experimental version of the
database stuff that used this approach
by using compiler tech to to construct a
class object okay that's interesting
one important one important property of
this approach is that it's surprisingly
easy to overload essentially all our
list processing operations to just work
with these
iterators or lazy lists
instead
okay
and so you do have a separate head but
you can still use select map first last
reverse and so on
one thing maybe to mention though how
does this reverse work i mean well it
obviously only works on finite finite
iterators and last but so it is
naturally
a partial operation i mean an infinite
list will not have a last element and if
you do a select you may never find
another element where the condition is
true so these are all operations that
may not terminate but that's just nature
of things
right and one one note maybe is i mean i
i don't know if this is exactly if i i
don't know exactly how this works but at
least when i've done similar things the
issue is usually that
um if you don't have some sort of
chunking it some things do get very slow
but but that might be okay in some cases
i wanted to come back to leonard and
hear more about his lasers yeah so um uh
what i i want to
make a few comments first of all
the chunking idea was specifically to
make things fast so
i realized that it's okay for large data
to sacrifice laziness on level of
individual elements
but what you get back from that is uh
high speed so that's why there was this
idea of chunking so
question when when you were applying
chunking and perhaps you're doing it in
parallel and so on
you had external code if i remember
correctly that was built to do certain
operations
out genuine away from the kernel out of
core is that correct
uh
well streaming itself usually operated
by loading certain portions in core and
then applying
things in core but i one thing i want to
mention is that
the abstraction of lazy list uh can
accommodate also operations which are
done on chunks which live elsewhere so
abstraction itself uh that is not
restricting us to
in core operation it's just more of that
implementation that i was using was the
one for in core operations in sense of
how it divides things into chunks but i
wanted to make a few more comments for
what what was just said before or
previously just now one thing was that
incidentally if you look at data sources
then the streaming was designed so that
all of these different versions actually
uh worked so i have a constructor for
lazy list on for all of these things for
explicit files for function base
generator and for basically an iterator
we have i had internal iterators which
basically uh streaming lazy list could
consume so one example i had was a file
a large file
you want to get from it for instance
first
10 000 elements and it will only read
file as much as necessary plus a little
bit extra so that those elements you get
those elements so basically
uh you feed an iterator which which
reads the file and lazy list will only
read as much from that iterator as you
need to read the first whatever number
of elements you you actually want
uh so uh so so yeah that that was about
okay so look to me
there are
two basics
maybe three basic stories here
okay claim
story number one templated array
structures
that means
if we look at all of these kinds of
things
those are array structures where
there is a a an underlying
you know
storing numbers in memory locations type
thing or whatever it is
and maybe strings i don't know that
separate issue
and but then there is something
externally templated about it that is
to the outside world
this should look as if it's a
you know list of associations where that
element is is referenced by this
sequence of keys and blah blah blah
right but to the inside world it's just
this in other words it needs a a
transducer of some kind where you know
if you think about it in terms of
not category theory but but i don't know
something uh you know what what's
happening a microphone is a transducer
right well yes but right but what i mean
by that is a two-way operation right
what's happening is
you have this
templated array structure
it is a quantity array of associations
of blah blah blah it has some wrapping
structure that says everything is in
meters per second and it's a bunch of
keyed associations but internally all
you see and it reminds me a little bit
of the neural net case because again
it's basically
grinding everything down with the net
encoder to the point where it's just an
array of numbers
this making sense so in other words what
we're going
from you know what we've got is
external structured data
goes to through some kind of
you know goes to internal
pure array of numbers
and then externally and then it comes
back externally to be external
structured data again it's making sense
so in other words let's let's say that
you said
i want to get the maximum value for this
whole thing right i've got the external
structured data
but now what the real the maximum is
really being applied to this internal
raw list of numbers
but then when it comes back out again it
gets the meters per second wrapped
around it again after the max operation
has been done purely on the internal
array of numbers
did that did that make sense
yeah what you're talking about is just
encapsulation idea right
i guess basically i guess
is this supposed to be something visible
like i mean quantity right array is
visible right now but are you talking
about making this well i'm talking about
generalizing this idea that we've got
for all these different array types to
be something more like this that is
there's a template
for what's happening inside then there's
an inside inside and then when you know
so so you know if we take it so the only
thing is um
actually we built that
and we're about to roll it out in 13-1
so
and actually those things that you see
there
quantity array
uh
[Music]
sparse arrangements symmetrized array
right
[Music]
the project we call structure array was
intended for something else but what it
did was to make the operations work and
so what it does
is to store if it has more efficient
ways of working
on that particular structure let's say
it's a vandaman matrix or something like
that yeah which the determinant of such
a matrix is trivial
right
if it knows something better it uses
that if not it converts to
um either all the way up to sort of a
general thing or it's some clutter
structure
but but here's a way to think about this
let's say we have a function f and it's
being applied to this templated array
structure okay
then what has to happen is there's a
transformation a change of coordinates
for f effectively that because
to get to the raw array of numbers
f must be transformed
like for example let's say i don't know
what's a good example of that but you
get what i'm saying that that is that
the thing you apply to whatever a sparse
array will be a good example let's take
the max of a sparse array or something
then let's say um
that
it has to
the pure max operation is doing
something different because it is being
applied to the sparse array values not
being applied to the dense list of
numbers
so as it passes through this this
structuring process
the external operation has to change its
character
does that make sense and then it has to
go backwards on the way up
it's exactly i just want to give an
example
uh in uh streaming that's exactly what's
happening because if you pass selecting
it it is getting translated into
some modified functions applied to
individual chunks which are based on
select but they are not real
pure selection
right so this is a general pattern
of there is a templated array structure
which could also be a chunked out of
course streaming whatever it is
structure but there is a it is a wrapper
that defines a structure
that is the external exposure of the
structure i mean it reminds me a little
bit of how
um for example data drop works in a data
bin again it has a
sort of a template structure now this
also is reminiscent of types
i would assume
because again types
well there is there is a covariant and a
contravariant
i think one thing that is really
important here is that
that
i mean the thing you have there on top
with the association list is very
because data set could have been this
but it's it it just wants to be
arbitrarily nested in something like
that which is something that we really
can't do for everything in full
generality while there is a very large
number of operations that you can do on
association list and stay within an
association list
which can be done efficiently even on
out of court data right but so the first
concept which it sounds like roger's
what i mean multiple people have worked
on this
is this notion of a templated
st i don't know whether it's necessarily
an array structure but let's call it an
array structure for now
something where
it gets
wrapper information quantities keys
those cut you know what what kind of
wrappers what kind of wrappering
can there be
actually is a quick question i mean for
structured arrays i mean is there some
like is there some interface where every
type of structured array provides these
10 functions from which you know max and
select and so on can be implemented or
is it more like you know you give a
certain set of functions that have
special implementations and if there is
no special implementation then you just
fall back on
it it's the latter christopher so
there's a there's a specific way of
saying how say i want to implement max
and you can do that for your particular
structure and if you don't do that then
it falls back on on converting to normal
or sparse array or whatever
okay makes sense
okay so just
what kind of wrappering can there be
there's very
surface level wrappering units
association keys those are essentially
metadata and there's also compression of
the array like a symmetric array where
you only store half the elements or
whatever
are there other kinds of rappers
yeah
i think we
list is also a form of wrappering in the
same way that uh quantity array is no
that's what i'm saying association keys
this is one of the the frameworks that
we implement go stretch differently far
i think what we learned with it the
structured array which was meant to be
rolled out some time ago but and and it
did but in more creative ways than we
had anticipated with jose
having other needs like for for
symmetrized array or quantity array we
hadn't anticipated those use cases and
we keep seeing more of those
um
that that it wasn't really designed for
but it actually sort of it's a template
that can be used for that
okay so i'm going to make a different
point here i think there's another thing
which is data structure transformation
so for example it could be the case that
the underlying sort of naked array is
actually a linked list
that's that i mean that's the thing
we're not completely discussing here
that's similar to compression of the
array by being sparse or something
um
uh
sure i mean all the data structures
support an iterator and that that means
you don't have to write it you know that
gives a great
degree of abstraction so like you can
have like map or scan or something works
over the data structures but you don't
have to write special code for linked
list or
you know well i know i know but what
we're doing right now with data
structures look what we did there was a
very conscious thing we we are having
we're not allowing you to just say part
of a data structure we're having some
explicit property of a data structure
which is its part whatever it is right
and we did that because we knew that
we're not globally supporting all
operations on all data structures right
so we don't want to give the wrong
expectations right but
what this is saying is
with the appropriate wrappering
it could be the case that
you know the wrapper automatically
essentially unpacks
if the operation you're trying to do
can't isn't known how to do with the
data structure directly with the data
structure i mean the only thing is i
think i mean this is maybe a bit of an
implementation thing but i think that
you we probably want to do a little bit
more than just you know if you're if the
function you're trying to apply is on
the list then it has an implementation
and otherwise it fails because the thing
is it's that i mean
the issue is that there's there's
probably i don't know
between 500 and 1000 functions that
basically operate on lists or arrays in
the language right
and and if you tried to you know
implement every one of those you know
replace parts et cetera you know for
every single type of array
individually i think that would be
pretty painful yeah so i mean i think
that the thing that you'd love to do but
which i think doesn't quite work is that
you have some interface where you say
there are these you know 15 functions
you define these 15 functions and now
you know intersection has a special
implementation that can work just using
these 15 interface functions and so on i
don't think that works in fully in
general because there are things like
you know i think symmetrized array is
sufficiently different from quantity
array that
those that set of 15 functions that you
can expose is like totally different
but but i think that there are probably
at least groups where you can say things
like you know the quantity array geo
position array
um you know
maybe the association list maybe that's
one group and they can have their own
interface and that can be implemented
for all these functions and then maybe
you know their other sets of
of you know sparse array and symmetrized
array and so on maybe they can have a
different interface or or something like
that i don't know but it seems like it's
worth having some groupings right but
there's also coercion chains where you
say i can't do this on a doubly linked
list but i can do it on something else
and there's a fairly straightforward
coercion to the thing on which you can
do it
is that related to what you were saying
or not
yeah and it's also a way to think about
importing in a way
so like if you if you think about it
importing from an external file is a
coercion operation
or converting between
two out of different out of court
formats sure well right i mean it's like
you could store it look it's like with
video with with video you are leaving it
in whatever weird codec it's in and
you're doing operations on that
similarly with a file you could leave it
in its csv format because it's not worth
taking that petabyte of data and
converting it to something with explicit
you know
with tabs instead of commas or something
making sense and so in other words
that's a case where where you're okay so
that's a different that's an interesting
case because this is where
you know they're different cases right
either you have control either
either you have control
over the
internal array
or
it's something you don't want to
something you want to treat
externally e.g it's a csv eeg an
external csv file
does that make any sense
so i mean in one case it's like you've
got encapsulation
wrappering that
you want to apply to an otherwise pure
list of numbers
in another case the actual thing inside
is something that's kind of from the
jungle
a um you know an external csv file and
then you're gonna have to do a version
of this you're gonna have to do another
level of function that unpacks
you know as the chunker comes through
and wants to see that part of the csv
file you're gonna have to convert it
into something that the operations
that get done on chunks can recognize
did that make sense
yeah yeah exactly and i think that
what what christopher is was saying is
very important like if we had something
which is a little bit like data
structure but i guess can't really be
data structure itself for these kind of
things
then we could design some kind of a
smallish api of this which include
transformations from one format to the
other
for from one data structure to the other
basically
and and on top of which all of these
top-level things like sword get
implemented
right
we are running out of time here
um stephen i wanted to suggest one thing
for the next meeting i could prepare
like 15-20 minutes uh brief discussion
of streaming where i could
expose i learned that through you know
very brief examples
that's fine that sounds good look i
think we are we are developing a
direction here i think um
you know we haven't addressed issues
like missings and all that kind of thing
but we are you know i suspect that yeah
i have an idea about how that might work
um
i think this is a useful meeting i think
we've got
i think it has many stakeholders
some people who have been here
who don't think they're needed for the
next iteration of this meeting should
drop out
um
but uh uh
the um
and uh i mean we haven't discussed
let's just check for a second people who
are here whose areas we haven't
discussed we haven't discussed
out-of-core machine learning
um
which we probably should discuss and
whether that's going to be very
different discussion from what we've had
here for something quite similar
um julia should be there for that okay
okay
um i'm not sure
uh you know things like okay numeric
array and byte array well particularly
byte array i suspect is a somewhat
different story that i i claim is not as
closely related to this stuff as other
things
perhaps i'm well know that that's that
okay that's that's essentially type
or type transformation right so that
that's a case where
gosh what the heck is that that's
something where you're storing
a
can anybody comment on that is that is
byte array related to all the stuff
we're talking about or not
is more of the numeric array
by the array is really just for transfer
not transformation
yeah right we have never developed a lot
of operations on byte array we've never
found a need for them
right well we have different operations
right we have string to bite array by
array to string right but that's a
transport i mean it's basically being
used as a transport layer
right it's not being used as a thing on
which you do computations
i mean we could have searches on byte
arrays but we don't particularly is
part work on byte rays
i think it does yes
can you do what
not
well you can do it with bit not i think
i'm not sure if vectorize is over it
like
yeah
very few operations work on byte array
right but it's still very very useful as
a transport
medium
which is what it was originally for so
it may not be the part it may not be
related to other things we're talking
about here all right i i would like to
yeah i gotta go but but um
should we get together next week please
do yeah i think this is gonna be useful
i think we can in probably two or three
more of these meetings we can grind out
something which i think will be a
credible design for this
it's going to take probably much of this
group to go through that
okay
thanks right thanks a lot thanks to
folks on our live stream too okay bye
for